why don't we meet up in the estate
agents get the keys yeah then go down to
the property have a look at the house
and then maybe just go out for a lot
lunch and we can just have a child for
lunch or something or or it leads to
coffee panthro great he's completed now
I'm on my way to Sheffield to meet up
with mark
and he was due to complete today but we
weren't sure what time he's just
completed which is brilliant because it
means we're going to get the keys go
around the house have a little tour and
yeah see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
and so on so the tax that you say
wouldn't be the same as be no but beyond
that I can pay no more tax anyway
because I don't take that for my income
out and put it through my business
instead of running the business with the
property of the personal income
obviously investors myself what will do
is once I've got a contractor in the
properties coming on the market I'll
give you a call a heads-up before see if
we can get your invoice visit come to
market
[Music]
so we're just going to kind of look at
the property now it's my first time
seeing it I think mark has seen it
walked for a while back and he's filled
with energy you know energy equals money
and I can just tell that he's got us
except for visits because how much
energy jobs so absolutely fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you put the rooms on for three fifth
day if you rented all these rooms out
for 375
let's say you spend five grand on fire
doors carpets the whole caboodle which i
think you should be able to do
I'm not buildable looking that means
you're gonna put down 25 grand deposit
plus five grand for all the bits and
bobs plus another say five grand for
legals and stamp duty so you're talking
about 35 grand all in which is about
about what it should be and then your
mortgage payments or how much 8
something say at a 5 Panna month your
bills are gonna be about what 350 yeah
corely 375 and then you're gonna have
basically isn't it so it's four 6s mind
up to 500 because of insurance so 500
pounds a month 375 times four is one
nine six day
- 504 - 500 everyone in month if you get
I love it if you get a grand a month off
this and you put that 35 grand that's
very good that's great
not far away but the fact that there's a
lot going on here as well it's good and
Sheffield's a real buzzing city at the
moment yeah really on the up it's
interesting when you look at the whole
house sometimes you can start 50 there
to do this when you look at the whole
house if it was only the bathroom and
everything else was immaculate I just
leave it but if everything's a little
bit then you need to decide okay what
we're going to do so the bathroom is
okay it's actually a perfectly it's just
the colors it's just like human yeah he
wants a pink mat that's it really
so it's changing these these are fine
I'm at the moment I haven't seen the
whole house more inclined to think in
new carpets and leave the bathroom
alright that's what I'm thinking and the
kitchens really nice
yeah but I wouldn't want to be spending
a lot of my I don't think you all effect
the wrench
you've got of always anything in the on
the ROI got me thinking okay I've spent
them I've had to run on the bathroom
what's the difference for the rent
[Music]
we would buy more houses in Sheffield
but they're a bit expensive sometimes
and also is a lot of article 4 so it can
be difficult but this one you bought it
for how much ninety nine thousand which
is which is great it fits it with the 20
and the 25 grand rule 25 grand palatable
room it's becoming harder and harder for
me to keep saying that as prices keep
going up so now I'm saying to people is
well look if it's 30 grand a room or 35
growing room as long as the rent is also
higher than 350 you'll still get your it
is absolutely correct and I will be sure
to use you guys again and tapping into
your team's your power teams to assist
me thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course
watch this video see what happens but
whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time